[Music]
on tv
on radio and on your smartphone this is
talk tv
[Music]
tonight on piers morgan uncensored with
me jeremy kyle commuter chaos again
strike boss mick lynch blames grant
shaps and the conservative party
he's got to show them that he's uh some
kind of steely right wing militant which
is what the whole party's becoming but
will fed up brits blame him he joins us
live in the studio health hazards at 50
beaches as failing water firms spew raw
sewage how can we cure britain's
seasickness and top grades plunge on
a-level results today but record numbers
are still heading to university
including a certain kyle jr many
congratulations al so proud but the
question tonight is still this is a
degree still the best investment in a
student's future
[Music]
so
[Music]
good evening my friends and a big big
welcome to piers morgan uncensored i'm
still jeremy khan you know what i was
going to start tonight by talking about
rail chaos and militant unions i was
going to show you pictures of deserted
railway platforms and scowling commuters
whilst lamenting britain's summer of
discontent i was going to complain about
selfish union bosses bringing a
cash-strapped nation to its knees in the
middle of this dreadful cost of living
crisis i even had a joke about minding
the gap between the timetables and
reality but then i did something i don't
normally do my friends i opened twitter
and it seems i've made a terrible
terrible mistake our nation is gripped
by mick mania the man's even got his own
fan club they're calling themselves the
linchpins those aren't just picket lines
you see at houston station they're now
cueing up for selfies with the
undisputed star of the summer union boss
mate lynch is a media star raves the
guardian make lynch a folk hero for our
time uses the herald we should all be
grateful for mick lynch commands the new
statesman all right wing papers of
course these reviews are make andrew
lloyd webber blush he's even won the
backing of bernie sanders in the u.s
yes it turns out my friend this picket
line pinup is currently bigger than
piers morgan's ego now admittedly i was
a little confused bowler so i delved a
little deeper and discovered why shake
this i kind of love a train strike saves
me 55 quid and gives me three hours of
mid-day back and there's no train noise
whilst working from home says steve
these rail strikes are just cementing
work from home practices that make rail
less relevant forever says andy another
one vicky i think i'll get a two-hour
lion yay more train strikes says vicky
and suddenly it all became clear
so as britain's most famous union leader
really won the nation's hearts and minds
or are the lynch mobs simply enjoying
another day at home in their underpants
well i wanted to find out and i have to
say and i'm going to do this to start i
wanted to discuss the rail strikes today
we invited the government no show we
invited network rail no show we invited
passenger groups no show mick lynch
though general secret the rmt was the
only one to bother to turn up and i mean
that as a starting point people will
criticize you and say oh he's never off
the tv
the only person that turned up tonight
what'd you say to that
well my job is to articulate the case on
behalf of our members we've got a job to
do we've got to get a deal that's at the
heart of this
there are some serious issues which have
been publicised but there are some
serious issues on the railway funding is
the main one to four billion pounds
worth of cuts have come out of the
railway system and i've got to get a
deal in a very different period they
obviously want to drive down their wages
they want to cut thousands of jobs
so it's a difficult job to negotiate
that and i'm determined to do it so i
have to come on the airwaves and try and
articulate it i want to do it slightly
differently me you've got a script
because you're brilliant at delivering
it i've got perhaps a view but i want to
do this for the people of the united
kingdom and i want to say something to
start with i think everybody would
understand
you wanting to get a better deal for
your workers as to what people think
about how you're going about it i don't
want to articulate that so we went out
on the streets and i've got three or
four people who
for you want to ask you directly
if you understand what you're doing the
serious consequences of your actions
have a look at this this is greg
i'm a substantiate recovery worker one
of my colleagues is off today because he
can't get to work
this is affecting not only him
financially and the implications that
follow that with not being able to get
to work
but also it's affecting his ability to
you know give out decent care
these people are already
not very stable
hence why they're in crisis and they're
turning to drugs
you're making a lot harder to deal and
give good care when our people can't get
to work
now i don't know why you don't do what
the chinese the japanese do sorry which
is
keep on running service just don't take
fair
let people get on for free
screw the companies not the people
it's interesting screw the companies not
the people keep the service going that's
a punter that's how i wanted to do it i
think that's important right yeah it's
important i understand exactly what that
gentleman's saying and it's disruption
we would love to do the type of action
that he's described
guess what the conservative government
has made that illegal for decades we
cannot do that if we do that they will
sequestrate my union fine us millions of
pounds and shut us down that is illegal
industrial action in this country we've
explored that with our lawyers and they
won't let us do it we would love to run
that service
even at the cost of sacrificing some of
our pay perhaps but a revenue strike as
it's called has been used in australia
and japan very successfully so that we
can run the system on behalf of the
people and be empathetic with their
needs as that gentleman was pointing out
we're blocked from doing that i think
that i think before we get onto the
tours i think the thing from uh from
from people on the street and we'll hear
from ashley a coffee shop owner in a
minute i understand you want to put more
money into the pockets of your workers
and and i said to the crew
jeremy we start with we want to save our
members job
money money let me let me say money in
their pockets but what you are doing and
this is what i want to try i said she
wanted to do it differently if you
listen to ashley in a tick
in in attempting to get that pay rise
for your members we'll talk about other
parts of the deal you are taking money
out of the pockets of small business
owners and workers and these people are
angry let's see if this is ashley davis
have a look at this if you can
industrial action taken by the railway
unions have affected us so much that
we've had no choice but to surrender our
lease to network operator and hope that
they accept that the company doesn't
have to liquidate comment we've lost
about 17 000 in turnover i've made
almost more of my staff team redundant
i'm having to get our local mp involved
to help us with our pleas for support to
be heard by the network operators our
lease agreement remains in place with
zero compensation and zero financial
support currently offered by the unions
network operators and the department for
transport despite requests businesses
like mine are the collateral damage here
and we've been completely overlooked
nick yeah i am proud of that as well the
problem for us is that our members are
threatened with in excess of 5000
redundancies
and the companies are trying to cut the
safety standards on the railway and
they're trying to chop up our terms and
conditions if we don't get a pay rise
for british people in this country we
will have a cliff edge recession people
will stop spending money in the economy
especially the everyday ordinary man and
woman will not have enough money to pay
their bills so they'll shut down
their expenditures and all of these type
of businesses will suffer because
british workers will not be able to have
that discretionary spend and there's a
real danger in this country now i i
remember a cliffhanger recession through
the
living crisis in terms of that cost of
living crisis that you talk about let's
talk about you the person when you know
that people are suffering as they are
and we've talked about energy bills on
this show for the last three weeks food
petrol absolutely everything and those
people not just on benefits and on
universal credit but those jams as
people are just about managing are
really in danger of going under do you
expect however much you morally justify
that the desire to save your union
members jobs do you understand that what
you are doing is further harming and and
causing more distress for those people
what do you say to those people mick
well what i say is our members are
losing money in this dispute as well
they are sacrificing their wages on a
principle and they have sacrificed wages
over the last two and three years we
have not had a pay rise on the railways
how much do you want
well we're looking for something that
addresses the cost of living but what
would you want if you let me finish yeah
but at the turn of the year when the
network rail deal should have been
struck the rate of inflation was seven
point one percent yeah we've been
offered four so that doesn't match that
cost of living so network rail tell us
tonight that then this is really
important they've offered an eight
percent pay rise hear me out no
compulsory redundancies extra benefits
to workers and their families and they
say why don't you put that to your
members they say that those members
would accept that eight percent i'm
doing what i have to do why haven't you
put that to your work well they're wrong
and they're not accurate in what they've
told you they haven't offered eight
percent they've offered us four percent
this year we had nothing last year so
that's four percent for two years and
four percent next year the retail price
index uh yesterday was 12.3 percent if
we were to accept that today we would be
underpriced for last year no increase
the year before and we'd be about a
third or perhaps a quarter by the time
retail prices coming at the end of this
year of the going rate of inflation so
if i did that deal and our members
prepared to accept it we would be
undervaluing our members productivity
and they would get poorer as a result of
that the cumulative inflation over these
three years is likely to be in the mid
20
that's the way it's going to go if you
add up all 36 of those months do you
understand the people miku say and i
know you've heard this line before but i
wanted to get it from you
you've heard the people say you know
nurses are on a lot less than than the
average rail worker care workers are i i
interviewed somebody from the union they
said well their union need to be
stronger and i go back to what i said at
the beginning that you're doing your
best what i what i i don't understand is
is is is
i get you want to improve what your
workers have
i'm just trying to ask you i suppose as
as careful i mean look for example grant
shep says he wants to make strikes
illegal right would you advocate your
workers still went on strike and
possibly face prison to get that pay
rise if it was that would you well we'll
have to see what the law says they
haven't published these laws grant chaps
keep saying things every week because
he's a desperate man why is he desperate
well six weeks ago he said he was going
to ban overtime on the railway the
railway runs on overtime because there
aren't enough staff
while there are not enough staff and
people have to work overtime every week
and some people have stopped doing
overtime because they're so alienated
from what the companies you've been very
you've been very very vocal about this
tory government government i describe as
a zombie government they're nowhere to
be seen we're a rudderless ship i wanted
a worse government than you than this
jeremy they're absent they're absolutely
i'm not a leader i am absolutely not
disagreeing but i want to talk to you
about labour right because you described
i mean stammer sack sam terry of course
for standing on that picket line the
other day uh you were quite i mean you
called him a soft tory at one point
let's imagine stammer was in 10 downey
street right now what would mick lynch
be saying to sakiya stammer well i'd be
saying to him now and when he gets into
parliament he needs to empathize and
recognize what working people are going
through people even on middle incomes
are going to struggle this year a four
and a half thousand perhaps uh utility
bill uh cost is going to affect everyone
let's not forget you've got to earn that
four and a half thousand with pre-tax so
you're looking really about a six or
seven thousand pound bill for even
well-to-do people in this country so he
needs to empathize with where they are
he could put a cap on wholesale uh gas
prices and oil prices which are produced
in the north sea fifty percent of our
carbon energy comes from our north sea
but bp and british gas which we used to
own in the public sector are making
billions of pounds not every year every
quarter so there is money in this
economy to pay all british workers a
decent do you think do you think that
starman would be more sympathetic to
your needs do you think for example that
the railway should be renationalized you
know that's something you might consider
the railway should be in public
ownership along with a lot of these
important infrastructure items so that
we know what we're getting so that we
know that they're running the interests
of the people and the economy and the
climate so that the profit motive is
taken out of those services and what
they're doing instead of course is
privatising the health service every
week it's being consumed by american and
overseas health care providers at profit
and they're leeching money and subsidy
out of our system as they've done on the
railways since privatization see here's
a test of 12 billion has gone out of the
railway since privatization here's the
thing right i decided to do it
differently tonight because i think the
script is the script right
final question to you mick and i and i
repeat what i said at the beginning you
came in nobody else did right that says
to me absolutely something um
what's your message
as you do what you do some people will
say you're holding this country to
ransom others and many will say he's
doing his best for his workers where's
the government get to the table do the
deal others will say he's just going to
do this as long as he wants it's all
about him to people watching this right
now the real mick lynch not that
straightforward what do you say to those
people who are frustrated angry what do
you say to them tonight well i've been
addressing meetings this week thousands
of people have been turning out to
support our dispute because people are
angry we're doing a job for railway
workers and other unions going to try
and do a similar job for their people
people are really angry about the way
they're being treated by this government
and the way that work is set up in this
society many people live on vulnerable
conditions they've got no uh conditions
of employment in the workplace they
could be sacked at the drop of a hat
we're trying to rebuild a balance at
work are you holding the gun away
no our people are being held to ransom
because they've been told that they're
going to lose their jobs won't have a
pay rise for multiple years and their
conditions will be ripped to pieces make
including their pensions i could sit
here all night and i mean i really
appreciate you coming on thank you very
much steve mick lynch today strikes the
beginning of many and next an
unsensitive results day but the big
question do you really need to go to
university in order to be a success
we'll do that after the break we're
coming back in three
[Music]
good
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back my friends now settle down
settle down stop talking about you lot i
might be the substitute teacher while
that nasty mr morgan's away but you
don't intimidate me thank you very much
of course a level results and uh
celebrations for many today
commiserations for some and for those
licking their wounds tonight here's a
thought that will balance your minds
prince harry got one b in a d and he
retired at 30 which proves that
anything's possible if you believe in
yourself and your nan just so happens to
be the queen now the best grades of a a
star were down look at this we're doing
it again eight point look at the money
that spent eight point four percent on
last year which sounds like bad news but
remember this is the first year since
the pandemic that students sat real
exams those top grades are actually up
11
on pre-pandemic levels and despite
fierce competition today 425 830
students have secured a place at a
unique uk university which is a brand
new record now one of those lucky people
is my daughter alice she got straight
a's she's off to the university of her
choice i can't mention which one because
nobody will talk to about al so proud
and so happy that you've managed to
achieve your dreams we're joined now god
uh we're joined now by head teacher
serge can you say your sir namely so far
many joking a financial expert gemma
godfrey and sam prince maiden chelsea
star and business owner who actually
left school at 16 has a very interesting
story to tell not a lot of time serge
let's start with you i'm probably a bit
old-fashioned and i want to point out
straight away i went to university did a
meaningless core course had three years
of having a great time and probably
would have done what i did if i didn't
do it are we now at a point where going
to university is not as important
relevant and guaranteed to give you a
job as it was in the past depends it
depends what you want to go to
university for yeah for me uh i think
for certain professions it's absolutely
essential but for others no
and
i think we lack alternatives for kids
with fantastic talents that i know i
have swept down the academic route with
lovely kids who maybe if we brought in
apprenticeships etc you know early on
target these kids something that can be
proud of that are credible that's a far
better way to go for an awful lot of
kids without them leaving university
which as you said a meaningless course
uh with huge debt and perhaps not as
employable as they were three years
before two things to you sam because i
know you probably think like i think i'm
not being disrespectful i think there's
too many courses in too many colleges i
think kids end up in huge amounts of
debt and it is not a byword to get a job
anymore that is not saying that lots of
people who get degrees don't succeed but
does it mean as much as it did in the
past
i don't think you know i think
university is
it's not essential i think life is um
life is of course itself i think people
have pushed down the universe when i
didn't do the uni room and i think um
i've learned so much of not doing that
it's interesting um you left school at
16. you said yes your your family had
money but your dad was was very strict
and you still straight now i gave you a
grand and you made it on your own and
that's a great story and you proved by
working your backside off that you could
make something of your life yeah and i
think it's a life less than the fact if
he gave me everything which at that time
i wanted everything yeah the fact he
gave me a hard time at a young age it's
allowed me to really work hard and
establish what my passion and dreams
really are um gemma um we're actually at
loggerheads tonight on this you think i
mean i i just i sound like a hypocrite
but it's not a buy word to a job anymore
and you end up in debt no no i agree i
mean i think i definitely think there is
value in certain degrees i think it's a
challenge because there are certain
degrees aren't applicable there are
other degrees that are of course if you
have an apprenticeship which i'm a big
fan of it means that you don't go into
debt you can get paid you can get a job
at the end of it but i think there are
ways in which you can do research to
find out which degrees are actually in
demand and also there are some companies
that are working in collaboration with
universities telling them the skills
they need and we'll give them a year in
industry and i think things like that
are getting much more pragmatic i think
going forward um
who was it who said net what was it you
sam who said your network
is your net worth agreed what do you
mean by that i think i i was i think
meeting the right people is great i
think putting yourself in the right
rooms and shaking is meant one thing
growing up is i want to shake as many
hands as possible okay take this the
right way because we'll be friends after
this isn't it easy if you come from a
better background to have that network
to succeed than if you don't what if
you're brought up in poverty what if you
know university is the aspiration
because frankly that might be the only
way to get on expand your mind and get
into a situation that you wouldn't
before if you were more privileged i
disagree i think you can put yourself in
certain rooms i think you can go to
certain places there's loads of events
every single week social media social
media and i think social media really
allowed that to reach out to whoever you
want and i think um in this day and age
learning is so free and i think you can
just meet whoever you want i think
there's a really i don't i don't agree
with that i think it's great i think
there's more opportunities but uh the
reality is contacts are hugely important
in order to get on agree you know hugely
important you've had a little bit of a
get up clearly your parents know what
they're doing the fact that they haven't
actually had everything i just i
actually haven't had to get up i i i yes
i went to a great school until 16 but i
haven't been given money no no but you
don't need you've got great talent
clearly i'm talking about the general
population if you like and we've got to
take get society to have a bit of a say
in what society needs out of our
education system if we just take nurses
as an example i'm sick of hearing how
many nurses we need yeah why are we
charging nurses to go to uni to get a
degree
surely something can be done don't tell
me about outside dentists we train for
10 years on the national health service
and they go private but that's right
honestly but let's just sort it out they
say i'll tell you what we'll pay you
we'll make you a bloody good nurse
excuse me you know but you're gonna have
to work for the nhs for a certain number
of years you also talked to business
about what do you want from our kids in
school you also talk about how yoon is
actually there's very little
face-to-face time now my daughter was
telling me i'm not going to where she's
going there'll only be two terms in
about 24 weeks what are you doing for
the rest of the year jim i think also
the other challenge as well is that a
lot of people are going to come out with
let's say twenty seven thousand pounds
worth of debt thirty seven yeah
exactly and that's a big decision to
make when you're 16 to 18 years old but
then you see that one of the girls on
the producers who works on the show said
to me it was the best debt i ever took
she said you don't start paying it back
until you get to a certain level did you
know that if you start you can't pay it
just gets wiped off if you go out the
country for four years who picks up that
bill but then do we get back surge to
the argument that which will go down
like a lead balloon there are too many
colleges and too many bla i'm always
colored by the fact that i i found out
years ago that you can go to the
university of keele and you can do a
degree in business and marketing and you
can major in brand beckham
what the hell does that do exactly and
that undermines the whole education
system as far as i'm concerned the
university is getting nine grand a year
the average that a head teacher will get
per pupil is five and a half we give
them 36 weeks my teachers work after
school
saturday mornings to make sure the kids
get the exam what are they doing for
nine grand because there is no face to
face pupil teacher ratios are huge it's
all online my kids have been to uni i
know what it goes so i think it's a time
maybe to have a look if we ever get an
education secretary here long enough to
actually look at things let's have a
look at what society needs from our
education system get every employer we
can what do you want for our kids let's
start off with you know what we want
them in on time every day
we want them to look appropriate we want
to be there we want a good attitude
that's never measured by anybody as an
employer i personally don't look at
someone i don't look at their education
and also don't look at their degree
which is great to hear but the the norm
i'm afraid is i did a cross section
upstairs 90 percent of the people in the
production office have a degree i'm
interested in this apprentice sorry i
look at it i think apprenticeships i
look apprentice i think that's brilliant
what you said just expand on that a bit
experience being paid for it no debt and
probably if you prove yourself if you've
got the job at the end of it absolutely
i think that is very pragmatic but i
think therefore it's two ways it's not
just about people trying to pick useful
degrees but it's also about employers um
embracing and giving people
opportunities because also from an
employer's perspective you get to train
somebody up you get to train them in
your way and you can spend three years
training your way up to the position
that again there are lots of companies
out there that they won't even look at
people unless you have a graduate degree
so my alice today gets the results what
tips for her and the other students who
have decided today that they're gonna go
what would you say okay obviously
financially it's going to be really
tough so here are my tips first of all
um look at student discounts the
national union of students they say that
they can offer people if you go to and
use all their discounts they can save
people over 600 pounds a year and all
the discounts it's for clothes it's for
uh it's for food it's for rail travel if
there were any trains yeah that one yeah
and a rail travel as well you get a
third off of off-peak travel as well um
also using go for second-hand books as
well for your course um if it's
obviously still applicable budgeting
apps also there are some bank accounts
that will allow you to open up in your
bank account and actually give you free
money um as well as a discounts on
council tax as well so you take
advantage of student discounts while you
can um you're saying you can do it
search very quickly you'll see
don't be pigeonholed it doesn't have to
be very quickly also very quickly i just
want to say about these apprentices
ironically the way the area where
apprenticeships are growing are for top
10 kids
all right those kids are going to be all
right anyway i'm sorry you're going to
get the best the businesses are looking
around these top companies they're
looking for the a star kids
we need another option for kids who are
great got great talent and are willing
to work which is which is what this man
is saying thank you to serge to gemma
and of course to sam next and uncensored
aha the summer the sun the sea the sand
and sewage yes that's right i'll be
speaking to the head of a surfers
against sewage who is literally sick of
it we're back in three don't go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk tv
[Music]
all right batten down the hatches ready
the lifeboats and peg your noses my
friends because the united kingdom has
been hit by a lunami
thank you a tidal wave of turd is
flowing across our nation and it's not
even prime minister's questions i've got
his dad here you'd be forgiven for
thinking this week's downpours might be
helpful for our parched and arid land
after all 11 regions have declared a
drought millions of banned from using
hose pipes but no thanks to our failing
water companies most of the water
falling in us this week is flowing
directly into the sea along with
thousands of liters of raw sewage
apparently the uk sewers can't cope with
the showers water companies have opened
emergency overflows to send the excess
water into our rivers and our seas
unleashing untreated waste into our
waterways rivers of crud you'll love
this they've turned the mersey into the
messi the star into the sour the trent
into the toilet and the avon into the
john
pollution warnings are in place at
dozens of britain's most popular beaches
the south coast of england is the worst
affected swimmers there are being warned
to stay out of the sea to avoid the
toxic discharge these people have put
the bog in bognor regis you see this my
friends is the scene in seaford near
brighton where dirty sewage water is
spilling out into the ocean frankly it
brings a glassly new meaning to getting
brown at the beach
i'm joined now big sigh there from noted
environmentalist the prime minister's
dad and on his 82nd birthday would you
believe it happy birthday stanley
johnson play it
[Music]
against sewage she joins us from fistral
beach which has been polluted uh
excellent good evening stanley let's
start with you if we can
um what needs to be done to the water
companies who are
doing this most irresponsible ploughing
raw sewage into our season our river
well i i remember when i was growing up
and i was a
early environment way back in the 60s
beauty you can go to the beach because
you say when you go to the beach you
don't um you know i'm not going to have
a swim i'm just going to go through the
motions you know
which pollution we moved on from there
but now i've got to tell you it is
really bad it is really bad and i'm just
terribly taken by what emma howard boyd
said and she's the chair of the
environment you know what she said it's
appalling that water companies
performance on pollution has hit a new
low
water quality when improved so water
companies get a grip on their
operational performance and then she
says for years people have seen
executives and investors handsomely
rewarded while the environment pays the
price stay there with that one second
stanley hugo tag him has to say uh
surface against sewage is this is this
normal is this something familiar each
and every year or is this a new thing
hugo
well look sadly the last few days is
something we're all too familiar with
dozens of beaches closed and polluted by
sewage pollution but we've seen this
year in year out last year alone water
companies discharged sewage pollution
for 2.6 million hours on 370
000 separate occasions and at some of
our most popular beaches between the red
and yellow flags they discharge three
and a half thousand times so this just
isn't good enough our bathing waters
languish at the bottom of the european
bathing water tables and also our rivers
just 14 of them meet good ecological
status i tell you what i don't
understand stanley and you've got a
point about the european union i don't
want to bring it to you your son right
there but the point is why are the
government not making sure that these
water companies don't behave in such a
disgusting environmental way what is
happening is we are not enforcing the
rules which we actually have him and
hewitt has made this clear point years
ago i wrote in the the eu directives on
on on bathing water we had a we had a
good framework for water quality
management that includes just a sewage
going into rivers but all sorts of
pollution going into rivers and from the
sea why is it not being i think what has
happened is we're losing the thrust of
this we're losing the thrust we're not
seeing this in contact we're forgetting
that
pollution goes to the rivers the rivers
go to the sea this is
not just a one country issue it's a pan
country as you where whereas i would
make the political point it's high time
we went back into what i call the
european environment agency which
enables us to see to see where we are
you know it's important we've got
british tourists who have to go abroad
to get clean water now um hugo uh you
take what stanley says the question to
you would be what needs to be done what
are your solutions my friend
well well look i agree and just to make
a
point on that uh in 2012 we were already
taken to court that the uk was decayed
into court by the european courts of
justice for the use and abuse of
combined sewer overflow so the water
companies need to invest their vast
profits back in to protecting the
environment and protecting the people
that use it not just surfers not just
swimmers but all of the businesses right
around the beautiful uk coastline that
rely on clean and healthy waters so do
the government do that whichever
government's impossible do they need to
force these water companies to behave in
the right way yes
it's got to do that he's got to deal
with it in terms of executive salaries
by the way
the lady i mentioned before emma howard
bought suggested the water water
executive reality could be sent to
prison it is a really really serious but
above all we need to have the mechanisms
in place but taking them to court and
we're losing that of course now that we
have left the eu and that's why it is
very very important that we build the
kind of consensus on enforcement it's
just to me it's tragic we're an island
we've got beautiful beaches and
beautiful beautiful areas and if it's
being decimated and and water companies
cannot do it morally they should be
forced to do so on your 82nd birthday
i'm allowed to ask you this how's your
son
well on my 82nd birthday i can tell you
i have had a a very friendly
conversation with all my children and
that's when i went to them all off you
take them
jeremy i'm not going to comment i'm not
going to comment i mean
he is he is what he is and as you can
imagine he is looking you know do you
want to hear my theory
yeah come on listen i think it'll be the
the envoy for ukraine by liz trust who
will win uh i think he'll do that for
two years because he's the hero there
who put the uk in ukraine uh yeah
absolutely and then and then what will
happen next uh is uh uh there will be a
hung parliament and boris will return do
you think you could handle that no
jeremy i'm not i'm not commenting on
this i'm here to talk about i know i i i
played you happy birthday i'll play it
again you did you did you did but
actually
does anybody play jab i meant boris
i was given a wonderful cake today bye
stanley i know you care about the
environment and i absolutely stand by
you actually people in the past have
said you don't care about the climate
you don't care about the environment i
will say this all right
boris's legacy does also include a lot
of effort on the environment it really
does i absolutely agree and 14 million
voted for him but i am allowed to ask
you one birthday question say yes chez
before i ask you say you can ask me this
go on
trust me now i
well i've got to tell you that by some
huge accident i have mislaid my
vote
and what's worse
and what's worse i'm leaving the country
tomorrow no actually on monday until
october the 15th so if i got you a
ballot paper now what would you do you
wouldn't because you wouldn't have the
secret number can i tell you something
that i've i've learned i mean we've met
before and you're an amazing man i
absolutely can see where bojo gets it
from
no i'm not
stanley thank you but we agree
absolutely with you and hugo this is
disgrace and water companies need to be
brought to task by whoever is in
government and if they don't do what's
right themselves they should be forced
to do final words that we need to
rethink go back into the european
environment ages which is not just the
eu it is 12 countries who are non-eu
countries it's unbelievable to pretend
we are not part of a much wider birthday
boy it's an absolute pleasure
he's gone absolutely no don't go nowhere
boris dodd well all right stand there
all right let go you go sir just be
careful of the step right now would you
take your baby to the pub the theater or
even a comedy show
bloody kid josh a parent did exactly
that at comedian matt ford's edinburgh
fringe gig and he wasn't happy writing
on twitter he said someone brought their
baby to my show last night sadly it
derailed large parts of it because they
wouldn't do the decent thing and just
leave when it started crying i get it it
must be tough as a new parent but please
don't bring babies to adult shows it's
always a problem so the question
shut up
so is it time to ban the baby will
somebody please see to that child for
goodness sake let's put we're going to
do it probably we're joined by comedians
sejila hershey how are you oh lovely
oh lovely lovely apart from the crying
baby can you please make it stop
shut up and journalist the mother the
five month old bargain rebecca reed
rebecca joins us as well rebecca good
evening
good evening oh good it's one of those
delays
because i have a very small baby there
we go see responsible parent didn't come
to the studio because she's got a five
month old segeela um i have total
sympathy with matt ford i do too you
know you write a show for a whole year
right that is our hard sweat and you go
to edinburgh and then actually it's not
the problem about the baby crying it's
the fact that he didn't the father just
want to say it was a father
oh here we go it's the father yeah i
didn't take the baby out wasn't it
responsible like parents so kind of
ruined the show for everybody else i
have had kids in my shows before i mean
i had someone dropping off an
eight-year-old just like some kind of
babysitter but the point is if they if
they are disruptive it's really just
polite to take them out i'm i'm
absolutely with you i i probably i want
to bring rebecca back in as the father
of five right i'm going to say this and
i will be
agreed with or not um i blame absolutely
parents why are you taking an
eight-year-old to a comedy gig i had
this conversation the other day with
somebody who said oh but you know i've
been on holiday this is what me and my
wife did with oliver is too right you go
out for dinner at six o'clock on holiday
in he's in the push chair and you get
back to your apartment or villa at 7 30
you sit on the balcony he goes to bed i
don't understand why parents drag kids
out to things that are not for children
and that's why you're at home tonight
right
i'm at home tonight because she's a
fantastic sleeper and i'm not willing to
disrupt her sleep routine to go to work
but if this was during the day i would
100 have brought her there is nowhere
between the hours of 6 30 in the morning
and 6 30 at night that i don't take my
baby um obviously if she starts
screaming i will take her out of
wherever we are but there's crying and
this crying right a little tiny whimper
while you get the bottle ready is not
the same as a big long scream i don't
think anybody defends big little
screaming but a little tiny bit of
crying might mean the difference between
being able to leave the house that day
and see other people or being in your
house alone all the time and you know
being a new parent can be insanely
lonely
do you think we're unsympathetic to to
very quickly
well no no that it's apparent i mean i
am i am a parent and i have been that
parent i've taken a son out you know i'm
a comedian so i've taken them to
afghanistan but then when they're crying
that you take them out that's a little
whimper
it isn't right it isn't fair
i mean rebecca you said uh you'd take
your child from 6 30 in the morning so
you take your child to a pub would you
100 i'm not at 6 30 in the morning but
absolutely i would take my i have taken
my baby to the pub a lot i'm going to
the pub with my friends and our babies
tomorrow why shouldn't if it's obviously
if it's a pub that doesn't allow
children i think that's their mistake
because mums are big drinkers but
generally speaking why shouldn't you
take your baby okay listen there is a
delay um question from one of my
producers who said why would you take
your baby your selfish lady and ruin
drinkers time who are going there to get
away from children just have a nice time
what would you say to that
do you know who really needs a drink
people with small babies
brilliant
that's right there are actually gigs
during the day bring your own baby so
you can that you bring your baby and
that's comedy uh that we know what we're
up for with comedians i would have
thought you said that comedians like
being heckled and you turn it around why
wouldn't matt ford have used the the
baby and the noise and just turned it
around and he's getting it it's like
having a horrible headquarter that just
rings a show it just derails the show
and our show is like a theater show so
when you go to edinburgh you've chosen
to go and see that show what about all
the other people who bought the tickets
isn't it their right to see that show i
mean to be honest like babies do cry on
planes we've all been with your parents
we've been that person there have things
changed since you were a mum uh
no no they haven't i mean i think uh are
you not more sympathetic to people no
i'm just a hypocrite because when i was
young when i was younger i took my kid
out but now i don't want to hear other
people's kids crying i'm sorry if this
is
very much like me on planes right you
know if i if so if i go and i get a nice
seat on a plane and there's a kid it
winds the hell out of me but if anybody
even so much as looks at me rebecca if
i've got oliver with me he makes a noise
i turn into this monster rebecca last
word from you
but we all know
well we all know that the rules are
different for our own children but
honestly we can all stand to be a little
bit kinder because i'm telling you first
time experience it's insanely lonely not
being able to go anywhere and please bit
of kindness people who've just had a
baby your body's wrecked you're
exhausted you might need a laugh and a
drink yeah there's a lot of drinking
going on and laughing so i think i think
matt ford and you're out of audience
you're going to turn into me in a few
years time you're saying that now trust
me you'll be the same the same thing at
miami listen i thank you both enormously
rebecca reed journalist and mother of
five months old margaret who sleeps well
so she wasn't coming here and sejilla
comedian mother as well thank you both
very much and next on and censored jesus
journals are back and it's the wonderful
duo mike graham and ava santina are next
we're coming right back in three don't
go anywhere
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh welcome back my friends let's uh get
straight to it jesus journalism tonight
uh talk tv legend mike graham and
political journalist extraordinaire ava
santine hello team hello my favorite jew
let's kick off oh
gambia toyboy ben uh middle-aged women
have been warned to stop holidaying in
gambia looking for toy boys the
country's tourism board says he wants to
attract quality visitors instead for the
last 30 years gambia has gained a bit of
a reputation as africa's sex tourism
capital ava santina go well it's sort of
like how men you know middle-aged men
will take to the streets of mayfair
maybe pick up a little 20 year old it's
kind of the same thing isn't it so you
know well mayfair i guess that's
probably where you find i don't know i
think mayfair is a bit more expensive
than that i think a couple of rather
nice middle-aged men and women yes to be
honest
yeah and i mean you know
i know there's anything wrong with women
going looking for for toy boys in the
same way there's nothing wrong with men
going looking for toy girls i mean
what's the difference is there a
difference i think there is a difference
there's a little bit more you know it's
a bit more predatory sometimes when it's
men going for younger women because
there's a power dynamic there that's a
little bit more frightening i suppose
but when women go to foreign countries
to pick up inevitably poorer poorer men
surely valentine's day and do the old
shirley valentine thing it's all about
the money it's all about the influence
it's all about you know or maybe
you'll bring him home and they'll have a
nice life together living in
bedfordshire i don't think it's fair to
put that assumption on gambia and also
actually the complaint from gambia was
that they actually wanted more expensive
clientele they wanted quality to quality
visitors instead of old granny's looking
for young boys i mean good luck with
that because that's where they go i mean
you can't help that i mean i'd like to
stop old men you've never heard it i've
never heard of people going to gambia
maybe like benidorm no there's loads of
there's maybe benidorm well i don't know
that's where i'd go yeah to pick up an
older man a lot cheaper yeah there you
have it there's an exclusive here on uh
jess's journal ava santina's heading to
benidorm to find an older place we could
richie soon at proving he's a man of the
people forget the fact his wife were
worth uh sort of 750 million quid
speaking to this morning never heard of
it the tory leadership candidate said
mcdonald's breakfast wrap was his meal
of choice from the fast food show have a
look at this is unbelievable rubbish i
get bacon roll with ketchup and the and
the pancakes oh that's brown though i
didn't yesterday but if i'm with my
daughters then we'll get the wrap
oh the girl's my eldest daughter is or
we get the wraps if i'm with her that
rap with the hash brown and everything
in it is what we do
he's lying ladies and gentlemen because
the wrap was stopped being served by
mcdonald's in march 2020 and
discontinued in january 2022. so there
you have it that's the man who wants to
be the next prime minister of the united
kingdom what a pile of old toughness i
think when he goes to the drive-through
he asks to borrow somebody's cheaper and
much smaller car to drive through it so
he doesn't look
i understand the pr team behind and why
they're doing it you know the other day
he came out it's not working though is
it over did you see the shoes he was
wearing the other day he had those
really expensive loafers on that had
like this perfectly
yeah there's a hole in them a hole in
them perfectly positioned he was sort of
showing off
all it does surely is prove to to
detractors who might say you've got too
much money to be a normal man that
you're just being forced man you're not
your football fan
i mean no
michael not really uh man united a
british billionaire jim ratcliffe says
he wants to buy manchester united
bloomberg is reporting the glazier
family is willing to sell a minority
stake in the club tonight uh malcolm
glasey brought united in 2005 for 800
million did he i'm not sure about that
the family been accused of taking a
billion out of the club uh radcliffe
worth nearly 13 billion he also owns
already french side niece yes or as
somebody said in the pre-production
meeting nice nice well it's not very
nice up in manchester at the moment if
you supporting united they're bottom of
the league right they've got the worst
start for 100 years um even ronaldo um
can't get any luck you know in addition
to being very very miserable and it
brings now he's now been given a penalty
notice by the police for slapping a
phone out of a kid's hand you know it's
not going very well is it i think i
think the point is that the glaziers are
living proof that foreign investors come
into british clubs and rip it off sorry
i think that's right but on though as
well i was thinking you know the talk
about him earlier was that he was this
you know he was going to an english guy
bringing in english investment he moved
all of his funds out of the uk in 2020
he moved millions out and it's all in
monaco so technically he's a foreign
investor as well almost every premier
league club has got foreign investments
i think they know that they would have
the money without it would they because
it used to be one of the easter the
third highest taxpayer in the uk that
anybody could afford to buy in the uk we
can't afford to buy butter everybody's
going to gamble
floodlights on
trustees to there you go
now listen i would i would make a joke
of this but i can't uh working you know
a study at leicester university has
found that a standing desk makes people
happier and fitter researchers
monitoring the seating habits of 800
office workers god do people really do
this for a living they've decided that
standing up is far more useful you you
you stand up all day uh well actually i
used to do a radio show when i first
started doing radio i'm not allowed to
stand up because the lights won't i sat
down to do the thing and they said there
you go they said you you don't sound
right why don't you do the show so i did
the show standing up for about the first
three years yeah and until i got better
at it and then suddenly i could talk and
sit down at the same time i love the
fact that my director ollie who's an
absolute legend said we don't understand
that we can't all stand up because it's
all stand up should we just daniel
how do you feel do you feel do you feel
more comfortable invigorated don't feel
invigorated yeah yeah i went to one of
the bosses upstairs and used uk the
other day and he's got one of those and
i was like yeah you don't sit down right
now i'm sorry i'm knackered i once
interviewed the first minister of
scotland and i was standing up and he
was sitting down he hated it because i
said i always start he's like can i
stand up no you sit there i'll talk to
you and so i was above him he really
didn't like it but people are walking
now as well aren't they they're putting
treadmills underneath their desks oh god
they're walking they're
yeah they are yeah they're getting in
like they're your ten thousand steps or
what whatever it is what are we meant to
get that is ridiculous also nobody has a
desk anymore do they because i mean
everything might come in yes
desking yeah you don't have a desk i
mean oh i'm sat at one but it's not mine
is now building his
in my ears because you know why he's
building his partner right because i've
disobeyed him and stood up so now he's
going to say you've got to describe as
essentially olds if we're honest this is
mr morgan's this whole thing is piers
morgan's isn't it even his name behind
you i know they couldn't even change
that do you know what i mean i not put
with jeremy khan no well apparently not
so you won't be voting for rushing soon
you won't be going to gambia or mayfair
i'm i'm not in i'm not a conservative
i'm not a conservative member so i can't
wait
because old stanley johnson told us he's
lost his ballot paper and i'm going
abroad tomorrow to the day after the
election wouldn't be drawn at all well
there you are i mean also you can vote
more than once i think or they say
they've stopped that but obviously they
haven't can change your mind apparently
yeah but rishi said that won't give up
will he keep everyone keeps telling him
you're not gonna win you're gonna lose
he's something like 13 to one in a
two-horse race ridiculous guys no chance
honestly guys i mean it respectfully ava
santalina mike growing back until ready
tomorrow morning at 10 o'clock i love
you both i'm on breakfast at 6 30. why
there you go thank you so much today for
watching uh it's been a pleasure we're
back tomorrow night late scott thank you
to the crew who are brilliant and
everybody in the gallery including ollie
who told me not to stand up wherever you
are make it uncensored have a great
night and have a good one
[Music]
i'm tom newton-dunn and this is talk tv
the most memorable moment in my career
without sounding completely conceited it
has to be interviewing president trump
in the open office in the white house
particularly the little red button he
had on his desk i have no idea what he
did is he went on one of the more moves
he's gonna launch a nuclear strike on
north korea or open up a shark pit that
i then fall into
turned out he pressed it right at the
end of the interview and he walked a
butler with a tray carrying it
here's the diet coke
[Music]
this is talk tv news
good evening i'm nadira tudor a leaked
report from 2009 says liz trust wanted
to cut doctor's pay by 10
the report also says she wanted to cut
large defense projects and slash
government budgets she's contradicted
this while campaigning to be prime
minister her team says that she doesn't
support every proposal in the report
greater manchester police have released
a new image of a man they want to speak
to in connection with an abduction of a
six-year-old child yesterday the child
was allegedly taken by a man into a
wooded area near a disused railway track
in drawlston on wednesday and top
a-level grades are down on the past two
years there were sixty thousand fewer a
or a star grades this year but almost
two-thirds of students got into their
first choice of university
that's all for now we'll have more after
the talk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you